des flammes pour symboliser la colère du
monde agricole
ce lundi sont venus de toute la nièvre
pour se faire entendre
un mal-être n'ait des conséquences de la
sécheresse a ajouté un sentiment de
déconsidération alors attaque sur
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires de les agriculteurs
empoisonneraient tous leurs riverains si
on écoutait et puis attaque aussi sur
les conditions d'élevage sur jeu sur le
bien-être animal à cette sortie de
nevers les agriculteurs filtre la
circulation quelques ralentissements
mais l'initiative reçoit l'approbation
de beaucoup d'automobilistes
personnellement ils peuvent bloquer
voilà moi je pense que c'est
donc ils défendent leur côté eux qui
nourrissent les grandes surfaces se
jouent pas le jeu il ne paye pas
peut-être leurs produits comme il devra
leur payer il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
difficultés on peut comprendre la
réaction en cortège les manifestants
rejoignent la permanence de la députée
peering où les une rencontre sans
débordement mais parfois l'impression
d'incompréhension entre deux mondes
moi je pense surtout que la politique
elle se rend pas bien compte
du monde dans lequel on vit et c'est
même beaucoup plus qu'une distance ses
immenses mais par contre les députés
ruraux ont pas forcément toujours la loi
par rapport aux députés des villes mais
il serait bien qu'elle fasse un accord
de temps en temps de ses collègues
puisqu'elle les amène dans une ferme qui
se rendent compte de ce qui se passe
un ras-le-bol écouté par une députée qui
se posant en représentante de la
ruralité face à ses collègues des
grandes métropoles
il faut une agriculture qui soit sur la
ligne de crête et la ligne de crête
c'est je pense moi pour connaître notre
territoire c'est ce qu'on pratique dans
la nièvre c'est cette agriculture dite
raisonnée
ils n'ont pas tort puisque pour discuter
avec certains collègues notamment des
métropoles on se rend compte qu
effectivement on ne voit pas les choses
parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
problématiques donc effectivement il ya
plusieurs france et celle ci faut
l'entendre il faut l'accompagner
la manifestation s'est achevée dans le
calme mais les agriculteurs n'exclut pas
de nouvelles actions pour défendre
l'avenir de leur filière